adrián won't arouse key ESPN senior NBA
insider set to join us and watch on the
clock yesterday was set to join us and
all of a sudden he sends a note to
fritzy saying can't do it got some
breaking news here so then moments later
two minutes later ICO woge is reporting
this is the new format 22 teams and
woods joins us unless a story breaks and
then you'll leave us again watch but
thank you for coming back explained the
information the story that you broke
yesterday again essentially the format
that you know we had been reporting on
that was headed toward today's vote with
the league's owners the Board of
Governors had been presented formally to
the owners which is a 22 team format in
Orlando five teams from the West one
from the east in addition to the 16 team
that were already slotted in the
playoffs and then a play in tournament I
heard you
you've got to read it a couple of times
to get how that works
essentially you're gonna play out you're
gonna have eight regular-season games
I'm told and at the end of those eight
regular-season games if the ninth seed
is inside of four games out then they
have a play in tournament if these four
and a half games or five games out then
the eighth seed goes on to the playoffs
okay is it gonna be east and west
designation or are we all under one roof
here it will be east and west and there
was some conversation around the league
about making it a 1 through 16 but I
think in the end what part of the
decision-making I was told with Adam
silver was that to change that in the
middle of a season when for example
teams built their rosters to compete
with teams in their conference and to
compete there and then to all of a
sudden change that didn't seem to be it
was too dramatic and sudden of a change
and they kept it in the in the two
conferences Easton was the home court
advantage the higher seeds what is the
Commissioner it felt like
there were quite a few things on the
table here Dave McMenamin of ESPN had
some of those but but what is real in
giving the higher seeds a so-called home
court advantage
well they'll get to wear their white
jersey yeah I think maybe I'll get to
decide what color they wear I do not
believe there is any appetite anywhere
in the NBA outside of perhaps the Lakers
and the Bucs the two top seeds in each
conference to give those teams in
advantage so I think though they'll go
to Orlando they'll compete like
everybody else maybe there'll be a
better parking spot for their star
player at the Grand Floridian but other
than that they're gonna have to win
straight up widely July why will it take
that long well part of it is getting the
teams back into market quarantined and
then the time it's going to take to get
them back in the shape they're not going
to just put them into a training camp
it's going to be essentially a couple
weeks of individual training similar to
what they've been doing in these
voluntary workouts but the league and
there's medical science people are
uneasy about the idea of going to
full-contact five-on-five regular
practices at the team's sites when the
players aren't going to be living in a
bubble environment they worry in that
way they want them to still be distanced
at that time until they get to Orlando
and so part of the conversation Dan with
the teams is well then let's get to
Orlando sooner and maybe do more of our
training camp there when we can run it
like a real practice they're very
concerned about injuries soft tissue
injuries the things that happen when
you're off and you get thrown back in
because they don't want they don't want
just this season to keep this season
from being impacted but next season you
don't want two injuries that let's say
the Blazers come back and maybe they
don't make the you know the playoffs
maybe they'll get in the play and a win
but you know what Damian Lillard getting
injured or you submerge to come back and
get hurt again because you haven't done
what's needed in camp time and so that's
what is going to ultimately you know
make people look and go geez this thing
seems like it should start sooner but
but that's a big consideration to give
the players a time they need I know the
Christmas that the NBA loves it's
Christmas schedule and if you're looking
at how this season is gonna impact next
season best guess of when next season
would start Danny I would be really
surprised if it started later than
Christmas Day that's such an important
day for television for the league the
idea of being dark on Christmas Day and
not having NBA games I don't I don't
think that's an option the league really
wants to consider but certainly if the
NBA Finals right now were to go to a
seventh game based on the schedule that
they've lined up and that they shared
with the teams you know I was told
October 12th would be the final date and
so if you're a team in the NBA Finals or
even a team that goes to the Conference
Finals that's a pretty quick turnaround
to starting camp let's say around maybe
right after Thanksgiving a month of camp
but you've also been off for a long time
your offseason it's kind of now you're
coming back you're gonna play for a
burst of time here and then come back
with a shortened start of next season
but it will put the league on a
different trajectory by starting in late
December where it's going to take you
again through the summer months next
year to finish a season Adrienne will
generally ESPN senior NBA insider his
podcast the woge pod the zion factor
here watch is there a zion factor of
getting him at least on the periphery of
the playoffs well there's no question
that he is a star he's been a star
attraction very quickly in the league I
think you could make the argument that
they were if New Orleans was where
Phoenix was five and a half games back
like I think you could make the argument
hey they're really reaching to get New
Orleans in Zion in this tournament but
the fact that New Orleans was just three
and a half games back
along with the Blazers and Trail Blazers
I think that is while I'm sure that they
love the idea it doesn't look as though
or doesn't appear as though they had to
sort of you know bend backwards to make
it happen I think there's more of a case
that maybe the teams at number 21 and 22
Washington and Phoenix I mean they're
right on the border being able to make a
compelling argument that they still work
lay off contenders how is the NBA going
to decide which members of the media get
to cover these games I have no idea I of
all the questions I've asked that is
that has not been when I've tried to
waste my bullets on or spend much time
on I I don't know what that'll look like
I do know this they they really want to
limit who's in that campus bubble
environment and I think what it might
also be Dan there might be different
different layers of people there might
be like a like a group like one phase
that does have daily interaction with
players that would be pretty limited and
then another group that's maybe on the
periphery and then another group that's
just within Disney but not around the
gym I think it may look something like
that but in terms of like broadcasters
those announcers be on-site I don't have
an answer as to how they're gonna do
that whether they're going to be in the
building whether they're going to be
doing it from their homes or from a
studio somewhere but it's certainly
going to be one of the those will start
to be more of the questions I think
asked as we dig deeper into the details
here we get past the book today I still
I cringe when I hear this that there'll
be an asterisk by whoever wins this
title and my point is there's only an
asterisk if the Lakers win this this is
the LeBron factor that nobody if the
Greek frequents a title nobody's
attaching an asterisk by this or if you
know Kauai wins another one it's just
LeBron is so polarizing here that hey
that doesn't really count as a full
championship I'm just waiting
for these talking points woods of yep
LeBron he won a title the whole season
has an asterisk by it but it feels like
if LeBron wins a title that he'll have
an asterisk by it see I actually think
it might be just the opposite of that
band and I think if one of the teams
that was considered the favorite a team
that's a one-seat potentially in the
West if they hold on to that I think
that there'll be more legitimacy if it's
the Lakers or the Clippers or Milwaukee
but if a team that maybe was in that
next tier wins and it feels fluky to
people because typically in the NBA you
know this Dan the best team almost
always wins that's not true in the NCAA
tournament that might not be true in
football where it's a one game but in a
best-of-seven the best team wins and I
think if if it's one of the teams that
are in that two three four how many do
we want to put in it yeah I think it has
more legitimacy then let's say the next
tier team jumps up and and gets hot and
steals the title and wins it I think
that's would actually be a more of a
team that might be seeing less than
legitimate I can't make you a programmer
at ESPN cuz you don't understand
programming votes you gotta have clicks
you got to have hot eggs you're not
getting a hot take if the 76ers win the
title come on you and your journalism
here how dare you you got a skip bayless
is saying what's wrong with you Woods
don't you understand it's got to be
about LeBron all the time well listen
it's going to be there's no question
that I think the star power of this
summer is going to have to carry the
league because you're gonna have an
environment like here's what I'm curious
about Dan I think the basketball junkies
you're gonna watch I'm gonna watch the
casual fan who gets brought into the
final to the Conference Finals who you
know increases your audience
exponentially that time of year I do
wonder how the environment around the
game impacts
I mean here LeBron makes some incredible
play and the Bucks call timeout and
normally the place would be going crazy
and is everyone just gonna quietly walk
to the huddle and the timeout and I do
wonder and so and I do think the
league's going to account for that I
think there's gonna be some bells and
whistles around the environment and some
of it may have to be manufactured it's
gonna be really interesting to see what
it looks and feels like in the arena in
these games you know some early games in
Orlando we've had those for years and I
mean you could literally listen to a guy
could be shooting a free throw Dan if
you were listening close enough on NBA
TV you could hear like two GM's in the
corner talking about a trade and so it
was not a electric environment I thought
you were gonna say you could listen if
you listen close enough you could hear
the guy's heartbeat at the free-throw
line
but are we doing its best as seven
throughout for every series best of
seven and that was one of in the terms
of what you're talking about Dan in
having legitimacy and crowning a
champion you know that people were going
to take seriously I know that was an
important priority for Adam silver that
whatever led up to the finals or the
playoffs I should say regular-season
games and then play in that that the
tournament itself the playoffs needed to
be best-of-seven and listen you're
asking for trouble if you have a first
round series that's best-of-five like if
you want to see the Lakers get upset or
the Bucks to get upset make the other
team only have to win three games and so
to me it never made sense if you wanted
to be sure the best team advanced don't
have a short series would great stuff
thank you we appreciate your time that's
okay
we you know we recommend Polynesian
Village for you ah well uh the
Wilderness Lodge
I remember reporting out the 2011
lockout at four in the morning in the
lobby because my family was sleeping
that's my great visiting memory Thank
You whoa thanks Adrian would arouse ke
the ESPN senior NBA insider in his
podcast is the woge HOD